[Música]
economía nuevamente en esta mesa del
trabajo directo américa en france24
daniela blandón vamos a iniciar con las
reacciones de mercado tras el ataque
ruso al puerto de odessa precisamente un
día después de firmar este acuerdo para
la exportación de granos y respetando
este acuerdo daniela como reacción a los
mercados entonces el día de hoy lunes
pues no volvamos a comenzar con los
precios del trigo de una vez al grano
este ataque gran misiles hizo que los
precios del trigo aumentarán
considerablemente este lunes ya que
planteó dudas sobre si será posible o no
implementar este acuerdo de la semana
pasada para abrir un corredor para las
exportaciones de granos desde ucrania
ahora veamos en wall street los futuros
del trigo en la bolsa de comercio de
chicago subían casi un 4 por ciento a
7.86 dólares el bushel esto es una
unidad de medida recuperando gran parte
del terreno perdido el viernes cuando
los precios cayeron casi un 6%
precisamente después del anuncio del
pacto ucrania ya dijo que espera que
esta misma semana se comience a
implementar este acuerdo ahora en cuanto
a las bolsas del mundo
europa opera con alzas ligeras en medio
de la incertidumbre sobre el gas natural
y también muy pendientes de la reunión
de esta semana de la reserva federal en
asia hubo cierres mixtos con leves
variaciones
especialmente a la baja un
comportamiento que es muy común raúl
previo a las reuniones de la fed porque
los inversionistas están cautelosos
esperando las decisiones que se tomen no
se mueve una hoja de papel en las
comisiones as por estos días ni una hoja
de papel ni un centavo daniela rusia
asegura que seguirá suministrando gas
europa por el norte 1 eso también tenía
en vilo digamos a todos los países
europeos dependiente del gas ruso pues
así sigue suministrando con un bajo
porcentaje propuesto ahora por ahora
todo está normal claro y la
incertidumbre se cierne sobre si es
posible que se vuelva a reanudar todo el
transporte por este que es el mayor
transportador de gas ruso hacia europa
el nord stream 1 y que acaba de retomar
operaciones después de un mantenimiento
de 10 días con un flujo que corresponde
hoy al 40 por ciento de su capacidad
este flujo que tenía antes del arreglo
pero los países están entonces
pendientes de si la instalación de una
turbina que acaba de ser reparada en
canadá servirá para que aumenten esos
flujos el kremlin por ahora de un parte
de tranquilidad y también culpó a
occidente de la situación
por supuesto la turbina se instalará
sabemos que también tenemos problemas
con otros equipos y si menos lo sabe
pero naturalmente la turbina se
instalará después de que se hayan
completado todas las formalidades del
proceso tecnológico y el gas será
bombeado en los volúmenes
correspondientes que sean
tecnológicamente posibles rusia es un
proveedor responsable de gas rusia fue
es y sigue siendo un país que en gran
medida garantiza la seguridad energética
de europa no sólo verbalmente sino de
facto por otro lado si europa continúa
moviéndose por este camino de introducir
limitaciones y sanciones de manera
imprudente que se golpean a sí mismas
entonces la situación aquí sería
diferente
sin embargo pese a esta información del
kremlin y europa se sigue preparando
para el ahorro el gastan y claro usted
recuerda raúl que la semana pasada
hablábamos de un plan para ahorrar un 15
por ciento del gas natural hasta 2023
pues la unión europea está analizando
cómo suavizar ese plan para exigir el
menor uso del gas a medida que se
preparan para un invierno de suministros
inciertos por parte de rusia porque
porque el proyecto original que
consistía en reducir un 15% ese consumo
era
una sugerencia que podría convertirse en
obligación y fue rechazado por al menos
12 de los 27 países 1 es porque están
rotundamente en contra de recortes
vinculantes y otros que no están
dispuestos a permitir que a bruselas les
controle el uso de su energía sin
embargo también hay países que tienen
planes individuales de ahorro de gas
francia es uno de ellos raúl que piensa
en un decreto desde ya para prohibir la
publicidad luminosa entre la una y las
seis de la mañana y también la
climatización de comercios u oficinas
que tengan las puertas abiertas baha
prohibir esto medidas que ya se
instauraron en ciertas ciudades pero que
quieren extenderse a todo el país con
multas que van desde los 750 hasta los
1500 euros para el que no las cumplan
seguimos en europa any pero cambiamos de
tema porque los viajeros están sufriendo
un nuevo verano por esta huelga de
varios trabajadores de las aerolíneas
europeas dan si raúl pues de estas
huelgas y la escasez de personal también
ya han obligado como lo sabemos a las
aerolíneas a cancelar miles de vuelos y
han provocado filas de horas enteras en
los principales aeropuertos lo que
afecta a los turistas que están por
ahora deseosos de viajar después de
todos estos cierres relacionados con el
kobe de 19 desde el fin de semana se
vivió una nueva huelga en la aerolínea
de bajo costo ryanair por parte de los
pilotos y también de la tripulación del
aeropuerto de charleroi cerca de
bruselas los empleados están exigiendo
un aumento salarial argumentando que la
reactivación del tráfico aéreo posterior
a la pandemia significa que los
resultados pues han vuelto a la
normalidad ahora la empresa ya dio a
conocer justamente hoy sus estados
financieros
trimestre éstos dan cuentas de ganancias
trimestrales por 170 millones de euros
muy por debajo de los 243 millones de
euros de beneficio que tuvo en el
segundo trimestre de 2019 antes de la
pandemia pero no son pérdidas así es la
de su utilidad pero igual no solamente
ryanair y la que ahí la que estábamos
hablando también precisamente la otra
semana si mal no recuerdo por es
invitado al día sino que también hay
otras que se suman sí señor el personal
de las unidades terrestres de lufthansa
también anunció hoy un paro para este
miércoles que provocará cancelaciones y
retrasos adicionales durante un día esto
según el sindicato llamado verde esta
acción incluye a los responsables de
tareas clave como el mantenimiento de
las aeronaves y es que los huelguistas
al igual que sus colegas de ryanair
buscan un aumento salarial ellos lo
buscan el 9,5 por ciento ya lufthansa
había ofrecido un aumento pero los
empleados dicen no no es suficiente para
nosotros queremos más en chile la mayor
productora de cobre del mundo retomó
opera y claro porque la semana pasada el
miércoles la estatal chilena codelco
había suspendido todas sus actividades
debido al fallecimiento de dos
trabajadores en un lapso de 10 días
ese día se confirmó la muerte de un
trabajador subcontratado él tenía 32
años y murió en la mina de chuquicamata
ubicada en el desierto de atacama más de
1500 kilómetros al noreste de chile este
evento se sumó al accidente ocurrido
diez días antes en el proyecto rajoy
inca también en el norte del país en el
que perdió la vida otro contratista que
nos trae como cifra el día dan raúl el
41% que ha caído el consumo per cápita
de carne de res y de cordero en turquía
frente a los niveles de antes de la
pandemia esto de acuerdo con la
asociación de productores de carne roja
y se preguntará usted por qué pues
porque turquía tiene una tasa de
inflación anual cercana al 80 por ciento
y eso ha hecho que por ejemplo el
consumo promedio anual de carne para una
familia de cuatro personas bajara de más
de 50 kilogramos en 2017 antes de la
pandemia a menos de 30 kilogramos en la
actualidad tal y como siempre muchísimas
gracias por toda la información
económica mañana por supuesto más
economía y más directo américa la
despido para darle para sumar esa para
hablar de deportes